oui oui fruit de données il avait un
ancien sportif français qui était de
passage aussi dans le département comme
comme raymond poulidor il s'agit de
dominique rocheteau
l'ancien attaquant des verts et de
saint-etienne et du paris saint germain
à inaugurer un stade à son nom aux
clayes-sous-bois sujet de catherine
m'vila tôt et lhjmq ans
une entrée en fanfare pour inaugurer un
terrain de foot cela se passe au ps où
joie et pour ce terrain la municipalité
a choisi un parrain sportif de référence
dominique rocheteau ancien joueur
vedette de l'équipe de saint-etienne et
ancien joueur du psg qui connaît donc
lire les aiguilles et que les jeunes
christian après midi un inconnu
quand surnommé l'ange vert pourquoi est
ce qu'on lui donne son nom à ce que tu
sais pas ce qu'il a joué à beaucoup
d'équipés avec un maillot vert
saint-etienne dominique rocheteau
inaugure le troisième stade qui porte
son nom en france l'occasion pour lui de
rappeler les valeurs auquel il est
attaché
pour moi les vraies valeurs du sport
sont éternelles il faut vous faites
toujours mais mais c'est un travail de
tous les jours fériés pour les voilà
pour les pour les véhiculer à travers
les à travers différentes générations
alors de solidarité mais j'aime bien le
mot de solidarité générosité
voilà donc ce soir ce terrain de
football permettra de recevoir des
joueurs toute l'année des clubs de sport
comme des enfants des écoles pour
accueillir les séances d'entraînement et
les matchs officiels
une première étape dans la reconquête
urbanistique du quartier de l'avre
c'était un engagement que nous avions
pris que la commune avait pris et qui
s'inscrit dans la rénovation de tout ce
quartier avec la reconstruction d'une
école qui avait brûlé et qui avait
laissé des traumatismes et puis
également donc avec la création d'une
aire de jeux aux alentours une réflexion
d abord l'équipement a coûté 1 million
d'euros financé à hauteur de 30 mille
euros par la fédération française de
football et 160000 euros par le conseil
général le reste à la charge de la
commune de résultats très rapidement en
basket et hand féminin t oui en basket
les trappistes enchaîne avec une
deuxième victoire consécutive ils se
sont imposés sur leur parquet face à
juvisy nettement d'ailleurs 82 à 60 ans
football en coupe de france
le poids 6 a été éliminée pour le 5e
tour face à au red star est en réserve
en eau et en féminin les féminines en
plus en plus de mal à remporter leur
match elles se sont inclinées face au ca
au sombre à venoix handball sur le score
de 32 25 coup d'arrêt donc dans leur
saison qui avait pourtant bien débuté il
y avait également du handisport
mobilisation autour du handisport ce
week end
oui tout à fait ce week-end la ville de
montigny concluait sa semaine du
handicap avec l'opération andy grimpe
notamment pendant une journée les
valides ont pu comprendre et ressentir
le quotidien des personnes handicapées
lors d'activités sportives images de
guillaume cance merci anthony pour cette
portage 7,8 sur le plateau avec de
nouveaux invités mains tachées piliers
les yeux bandés ou assis dans un
fauteuil roulant
le temps d'une journée les valides ont
pu ressentir le quotidien des personnes
handicapées
lors de la dernière journée de la
semaine du handicap organisée par
montigny le bretonneux civique en
passant par la porte c'est par ces
durées et pourquoi les personnes est
toujours un fauteuil roulant ça doit
être dur c'est bien oui que tout le
monde puisse un jour se dire moi je j'ai
la chance de pouvoir remarcher de d'être
en bonne santé
comment d'autres personnes peuvent vivre
au quotidien ce qui pour nous semble si
facile
le défi le plus complexe était
certainement en 10 grains tenté
d'escalader avec un handicap artificiel
mais les valides avez la chance d'être
accompagné par les membres de l'équipe
de france d'escaladé handisport
malvoyantes de naissance
roxane ali a décidé de grimper au haut
niveau il ya quatre ans et sa passion
elle a dû la prendre au gré des parois
quand on est mal voyance est un peu
c'est l'un des sports que vers lesquels
on ne dirige et quand j'en avais fait
quand j'étais en classe découverte en
école primaire aux écoles spécialisées
qui après au lycée dans cette unité
spécialisée et une fois que j'ai fini
j'ai eu fini lisse et je me suis dirigé
vers le cloud
bon je grimpe il faut que je sois guider
donc quelqu'un va me dire d'aller où
sont les prises et ça ça s'acquiert à
force d'expérience il ya quelques
semaines l'équipe de france d'escaladé
handisport a glané deux médailles aux
championnats du monde qui se sont
déroulés à paris
comme quoi avec un handicap on
recommandera vient de montagne ça m'a
permis de m'ouvrir et c'est ce que
j'essaie de faire justement essayant d'y
grimper ses films et tout ce que je suis
dans ma vie de tous les jours c'est dad
quand on arrête de se prendre la tête
voir la vie elle est vachement plus que
ça